foreign
audit and risk meeting
are there any any apologies
I don't
don't see I think rich Paul do you know
where Richard is
yeah
you're not keeping not keeping Young
Brother under control then
okay well yeah well he may show up okay
it's not put them in apologies I can't
record it okay
uh are there any conflicts of interest
with the agenda we got in front of us
no okay well
we'll move on to the to item one email
archiving with cybus security trains as
at the 30th of June 2023 yeah actually
I've got
Andrew have you got any comments you'd
like to make on this report
uh no
um it was uh through the chair
it was um just to give you guys a little
bit of an insight into what our normal
um
activity is like and as you'll see in
that uh it's second graph that we've got
a we had a fairly substantial Spike that
that lasted for several weeks
um
and it might be conflating
multiple events but it was an
anti-recent one to see probably more
important is the email archiving
um
down in the basement we have what are
called the pink punches
which is all the uh the copies of memos
that were typed up by the typing pool in
the 1970s I think Susan that's it
and before yeah
um so go back 40 years and and most of
our
um
interaction with with various external
parties was through the form of mimos
um now most of it is done through email
so from an information management
perspective
um
that becomes one of our primary
information stores
and from a risk perspective
um
by
archiving all of this into our external
archiving platform
we have a record of as I think I wrote
about six million items
over the last
20 odd years so it's a that's a pretty
important piece of History
and from an archives New Zealand
perspective it's a pretty important one
so it's a it's a really nice project to
have finished
so um
just a shout out to dilip
who was our infrastructure engineer
um who unfortunately is leaving us in
three weeks time but um it's been a
really big project that he's been
working through for
eight months
archiving and finding things is very
important
particularly when you're an accountant
like me and they have Auditors wanting
audio reports that's what I've spent the
morning doing this actually finding the
last year's information for them
uh through you Mr chair thank you for
that report those emails that have been
rejected are they all incoming from
outside the network or some of that on
the side
uh majority of them were outside I think
um having said that
um
yeah as I said it just takes takes us to
be on one mail list there is nothing
there outside is that the majority of
them were on a on a block list nabielle
that's through you Mr chair they when
was the last time we did the fishing
test on staff
and what pass rate did we get this time
um it was about uh nine months ago
um and we had one or two fails
um we picked quite a nice scenario in
terms of three Waters we thought we
would like to get a few hits on that
um I won't say who failed
um and
I won't say when we'll be doing the next
one
unless you can promise it's not going to
outside this room
Joe
there are three again Mr chair
um
yeah just to follow on on similar
similar field do we have any ideas
intrusion detection system within the
network for detecting anything that's
potentially going out
that hasn't been initiated by us
we have
lateral intrusion detection
so
we have a platform that is monitoring
for incursions and for lateral movement
within the network
and we have
um
systems that are watching for a known
devices on the network
um but I'm just a little bit hesitant to
go into too much detail because
um
it's public form
thank you are there any other comments
on this report
would someone like to move that report
be received
Michael and seconded by Joe
or all those in favor please all right
make sure I've got the song the next
report is the three Waters quarterly
service report
this is when Aaron do you want to
comment on this please uh thank you
um
this report is just to give you
um I've added a year in graph to give
you an idea of where all the tasks have
come from
after hours on antenna email internal
telephone
Etc
um apart from that I'm happy to answer
any questions
does anyone have any questions for Aaron
on this report
Michael then Joe
the the response to the company request
on the flooding event where it took us
if I'm reading it right 88 Minutes
against a target of 60. is there any uh
good reason as to
what led to the missing of that one
through you Mr chair
um that response time was during a
rainfall event at Christmas or just
before Christmas
where Gore sustained quite a lot of
flooding in the CBD Etc so that night
there was a number of our staff out to
the small hours of the morning
um so yeah that's why that one was a bit
bit outside the norm
no someone's been copying my notes he's
asked the questions
have been
thank you Mr chair I'm just following
along those lines with recent events
with Snow Mountain we have any
difficulties with our Network or was
that primarily in the rivers themselves
through you Mr chair uh yes we did have
some issues
um we are investigating some
possible outcomes for that in Frank
Street and Coots Road area
we had
um
some a couple of property owners that
called about some flooding that was
going through there so we're dealing
with the neighboring property to see if
we can resolve that
anyone else have any questions or
comments on that report
would someone like to move that report
will be received
Paul and seconded by bromwood
all those in favor please say aye and
against
carriage
we've got the monthly compliance update
report Aaron you're on again
thank you Mr chair
um
this report is part of our ongoing
compliance requirement to tamata arawai
we have to submit our monthly compliance
on all our water treatment plants
and yeah as you can see we've had two
non-compliant days for Matera this is
while the water treatment plant is
undergoing its upgrade
um and yeah we everything else of the
plant was compliant on that day
happy to take any questions
anyone have any questions for Aaron on
this report
all good
would someone like to
no oh you've got a question sorry wrong
your move
okay second from Joe's second
all those in favor please say aye acting
against carried
now now we let's move on to the next
report which is the fraud policy
we've got
okay would you like to just brief us on
this report please
uh through you Mr chair
um take the report and the proposed
amended policy is read uh reasonably
straightforward of course is stipulated
by the um uh policy prioritization uh
cheered at the last audit risk committee
meeting
um what this uh Amendment aims to do is
to update the policy uh to the 2023 era
[Music]
um
bringing it in line with other uh
similar councils in terms of how
um
reporting procedures are gone through
and also kind of fixing some holes that
were present in the last
um for policy
and uh with that I'm now at your
disposable for questions
anyone have any questions
from
the question as such just to comment on
the fact that the wording has been
changed for a recommendation to
terminate an individual I was worried I
might have had to pull a trigger so well
spotted and pleased that it's fixed
so Joe you're through Mr chair
um just looking at bullet point number
three actions Consulting fraud I see
there's nothing in the air that sort of
stipulates giving graft it's all about
taking
um or dishonestly and receiving it's not
you're not looking for people to
actually
so paying the money to get the end
result I'm just wondering if something
should be defined in those terms in
there
uh through Mr chair we can definitely
add something along those lines
um of course probably along the lines of
bribery
um yeah that is our common path for the
course uh for instance the Central otago
District Council maintain a fraud
corruption and bribery policy so to make
absolute sense to add that in
um
move it to catch-all and the sense that
it talks about impropriety and the
handling or reporting of money or
financial transactions so the handling
of financial transactions and payments
going out will be covered under that as
well
Michael Mr chair I got a couple of
questions
in the report
in the
sixth paragraph down that says we want
to foster a work environment we're for
fraud is discouraged
I would have thought we'd want to more
than discourage it
and and therefore are we not are we not
setting the standard high enough that's
one comment
I then
do we have a fraud register
you Mr chair the the fraud register
hasn't been needed in the past there is
a template there but nothing nothing has
been logged to date
I guess I'd argue that we should have
one and it's really good that there's
nothing in it
but but it's something that we should
get and the register should come to the
audit and risk committee on a regular
basis even if it's blank so we're making
it a conscious decision
the
we then use terms like senior leadership
team
which
I'm sure everybody here knows what that
is but as an outsider looking in it's
not defined within the policy
simulation time breaker is TL
yeah but who makes it up yeah
the and then the next question or
comment I've got is
should the audit and risk committee have
a formal role or responsibility in terms
of the
policy
through you Mr chair the ordinary risk
committee could actually be the policy
sponsor as opposed to the gym of
corporate support so that would elevate
it up into the importance of of this
particular policy so if that's a change
that the audience committee would like
we can change the policy sponsor to
being auditing risk committee
uh well I'd encourage that next question
I had related to trying to get clarity
around what happens if the
fraud or the alleged fraud uh is it the
level that would involve the CEO or the
mayor and whether we've got enough
sort of a framework around for making
sure we handle that with the sensitivity
that it needs
I didn't gain the impression that we did
the potato disclosures policy and
there's some framework in that that
would be transferable to to this policy
but we can produce some guidelines that
accompany the policy and make it very
very clear on how how when what why and
bring those back to order the risk if
you would like
uh the and the next question I had was
under paragraph eight
and
I wondered whether
and the investigation if it involved
quite a complex digital
fraud whether within the council we
would have sufficient
knowledge or skill set to do the
forensic work
or whether we needed to have the chief
executive with authority and maybe he's
got the authorities in some other policy
to actually call in an expert
absolutely the MP for the chief
executive calling the Specialists when
needed we can make a completely clear in
this policy just for about some braces
to make sure that there is stated there
but the council has done that in the
past and will do it as and when it's
needed to bring Specialists and for
specific pieces of investigative work
and the last one I had is under 12 it
says that the fraud policy will be
reviewed every three years I'd quite
like that to be at least every three
years
Morgan did you want to say something
there
uh just through you Mr chair just in
relation to the delegation of the chief
executive to bring in uh external
Council that is noted under Section Five
of the fraud policy
other persons such as me and my
assistant chief executive in conducting
an investigation
um
so that can be expanded upon to formally
stipulate bring an external Council if
needed if necessitated by they are fraud
in question
yeah my observation is that if the
alleged fraud
involves anybody that person has to be
very clearly excluded from the the
process
of council Australia
Moda just add to that
um
and part of that process some of them
some of it can actually be
used internally to catch them out of
fear you're giving them certain
information as well on that process so
that would come down to defining who's
doing the job and what's required of it
I'd feel
now the comments or
on this policy
be with me a minute because you've got
quite a few changes there do you want to
you want to bring it back
oh yeah
so I think seeing we've made so many
adjustments to this policy we perhaps
hold it over uh
to the next meeting for for formal
okay
so we'll leave that
thank you Mr chair could I just suggest
that um potentially the the
committee saw endorsed the policy with
those recommended changes when it comes
to council and then it just expedites
the process rather than it coming back
to this committee and then to full
Council
um if the if the James comes with it
yeah fantastic
so we all comfortable with endorsing
this policy and we'll
then take it to the full council meeting
when the changes are made
okay right I think
could I have a
a movement
jungle Chamberlain and councilor guard
on a seconder all those in favor
against
carried
right
the next item on the agenda is the
report on lagoima's requests
so
oh sorry on this one
apologies sundry debt is right off at
the 30th of June
nor name would you like to speak tonight
thank you Mr chair this is I feel a
fairly straightforward report and as a
tight a year and tidy up that we do
every year we just thought it was useful
to bring it to to order risk and this
deals with sundry debt is only not
rating debtors
date
but in general the the total debt's
written off and during that period was
um less than ten thousand dollars in
total there's only one quite large one
and it was to do with a noise complaint
to repeated noise complaint issue that
um they escalated so
really the report is just for Just for
information receiving
oh
a couple of questions uh it's good
information and thank you I'd quite like
to see a positive statement on the
report in future years that there's
nothing in the debts that were written
off that senior people within the
council have a conflict with
and I'd like that positive statement and
also that there is nothing that's been
written off that if it was an item of
expenditure would have fallen under the
sensitive expenditure policy
it's Chamberlain and through you must
share that they're really good
suggestions I can confirm having looked
over the list that there was nothing
there that a senior manager or a staff
member would have had a conflict of
interest over knowing the smallest that
was there and there was nothing of a
sensitive expenditure nature they were
all mostly have to do with noise
complaints and I think there was a small
couple of small parking fines that were
written off as well so they were all
awfully really routine
councilor mcfail
thank you through the chair noise
complaints annoy me um I want to know
whether this is is it a one specific
problem that hasn't been sorted like
that is it a continual thing and is is
it we're just writing it off and they're
going to continue this
can we confiscate the gear and things
like that we can
yeah three years the the gear was
confiscated at that point in time and it
is still in our position their debt has
been transferred to debt management so
it is on record there for any time in
the future this particular individual
um was caught on twice
um and other type of individual that you
would not receive the money out of but
it is on their record and without going
to too much detail on the individual
um so that was that was the big one and
the two there's two more reasonable size
five six hundred dollar ones in the in
these other 13 that were written off
they're around noise complaints as well
and it was a certain period of time
between November 2021 and February 2022
remembering the the latest line items
that we've got that um that these
occurred so it's during the summer break
of some time of their particular year
and again those types of individuals
whilst we have tried and transferred the
debt to debt management to collect have
been uncollectible so it's still there
if they do get some luck in future and
gets collected then we will receive that
bit at the moment it's prudent to write
those small numbers off
okay thanks very much so do we have any
recourse again if they come back
can we grab anything else of these
like the house would do
but do we have any any way of getting if
they continue
we'll say if they can
do have noise complaints they haven't
they haven't been complaints against
those properties since that are on there
that they're still outstanding
um so yeah we we're hopeful that they
either moved on from the district or
learned their lesson
thank you very much
councilor Stringer
oh it's through you Mr chair
um thanks for that you mentioned that
they the debtors passed on to the
details do we also pass the collection
fees onto the dealers too so the council
is not lump was that or any Associated
fees
yeah Mr chair the espionalities are
added to to these which is part of the
reason why their particular one is high
but we do we do seek to get collection
fees from them as well
sustainable comments on this report
would someone like to move that we
except cancel the guard on Council the
Stringer seeking
all those in favor say aye
against carried
thank you through the chair
um I'll just take the reporters read I
suppose just a bit of an update these
figures are just to the end of May
um so we've still got June and July
figures to include in the next report we
have in May and June process to 31
legolymers which is
probably what we're doing a normal year
um and yeah look forward to it slowing
down hopefully
councilor read
thank you Mr chair just a question for
the manager
I know that we give the first hour free
do other councils do the same
or is it just us
yeah there is normal practice across
other councils you can charge thereafter
in each request that we get in as
assessed in terms of how much time would
be required there is quite a high
threshold the Ombudsman has quite a high
threshold if you are going to charge
um so yeah we do have that ability to do
it
you think thank you
um given that um we've been a bit
inundated and user pays
it might be time to look at maybe the
odd
um repeat
person or six
just a thought
through Mr chair
um my hat goes off to you staff dealing
with all that like what you said if
you're dealing in one month what you're
dealing in a year that's that's quite a
bit to work through
may have been
just a few questions here uh the first
is around uh creating a page on the
council's website where these look
members will be
published I totally understand about
transparency I guess
um a good test of understanding from
staff
um how this decision was made and more
so around
I guess we we inciting more risk of
someone
doing a leguma fishing and then everyone
else being able to see it and getting
that same information adding adding to
scrutiny um that's just called what I
see from it
um just if I get the members of opinion
on there that makes sense sorry
through the chair
um it is common most councils will have
a page on their website which a lets
people know what a leguma is and
encourages them and helps them how to
make a request we've got to remember
that the actors based on the principles
of transparency and open government and
often we find you'll spend a lot of time
doing a response to a leguma and then
what you may see in a public arena is
not actually a true reflection of what's
provided so it also will save us some
time because if we do get repeat
requests for some of the things we can
direct people to that page
fantastic thank you for that really
appreciate it um the the second night
question I had with that page was just
around privacy
um will the these names of the requester
um just around the Privacy actor we
we hit those requirements
disclosing people's names yes so the um
individuals names will not be disclosed
but where you have entities likes of
um stuff
um taxpayers Union you know
organizations such as that then they
will be disclosed
thank you for that I guess just for for
these reports because they are in public
it might be good to have have the names
objected
um and the third uh not so much of a
question but a comment was just on that
last recommendation
um that staff report back to the
committee in six months just wondering
whether we could change it slightly that
the report back for at least the next
six months um so that we get it
consistently over the next three
meetings um it would just be good to see
those Trends if that isn't too difficult
for the GM
no that's that's fine we can produce a
report to each of the committee meetings
in the future thank you
thank you Council Marie thank you Mr
chair just another question for Sonia
sorry
um so when those um things are published
on the website the replies will be
published as well
or just the information requested
uh no the replies will be published um
with the pages actually almost live now
I think I'm I'm not too sure but
basically it will contain the um a
synopsis of of the request and then
it'll have the full response that we
provide with any supporting
documentation that is required or
provided to the requester yep thank you
that sounds really good appreciate the
any other counselor have any comments
or report or any questions
if not I'll ask for a mover
Council Reed seconder
mayor B and Bell
all those in favor say aye I am against
carried
well now move into the public excluded
part of the meeting
let's go let's have a break for a minute